obviously going to take to analyze this
agreement
okay I think it's it's so divisive it
will take a little bit of time
um certainly we have to analyze the
document uh we have to see what its
longevity is uh how we future proof uh
the document remember it only rather
than my entry uh on on Monday afternoon
and we won't Trail this before how so we
knew nothing of it and there were some
surprises in it
um so it's going to take us some time to
look at that and then we have to make
sure we engage with the wider party but
I certainly don't think it's going to
take weeks and certainly it should not
take months any political party should
have the structures in place to be able
to do the analysis on this and come up
with their decision uh in in a week or
certainly no more than two weeks
what sort of surprises are you referring
to there that were in this agreement
that you weren't expecting well I I
think the storm break was was the one
that uh surprised us the most as a
political party we put in many ways of
dealing with some of the problems or we
did say use the structures of the
Belfast uh Good Friday agreement in
order to deal with some of the issues
we've got around at the protocol and
they've done that with the petition of
concern but we weren't expecting that
and we still don't know fully how that
is actually going to work so we've got a
number of rfis that we will put into
that government to see if we can get
some answers to to that in a bit and a
bit of clarity
okay what about these um green lanes
that we are hearing about we're told
that that means that there will not be a
border of uh soft hardboard or whatever
in the Irish sea but really my newspaper
this morning that is suggesting
potentially otherwise other checks will
still be in place including random
checks
yes and and let's be absolutely clear
there was always checks of some
description between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland even before
um brexit um certainly after the the
foot and mouth we had checks uh on on
animals certainly coming into Northern
Ireland so checks were always there it's
all about the level of checks and goods
that come routinely from Great Britain
to Northern Ireland that are staying and
for consumption in Northern Ireland
should not routinely be checked but of
course there will be checks which are uh
intelligence-led checks to stop
smuggling to make sure people aren't
abusing uh the system
um but Goods that are coming through
Northern Ireland going into the European
Union into the European Union single
Market I think it's fair to say that
that that that they need to be checked
and and I don't think that anybody
should take too much of an issue with
that
okay so there will be a border there as
as we as you're illustrating when
Michigan sunak it came yesterday so sort
of what what was the mood music what was
it like in the room with people pushing
him on the back or was it cautiously
optimistic or how was he received
no I look you know I met with the Prime
Minister and I thanked the Prime
Minister for what he's done uh and his
team has done to get us to work to where
we are um but I did say to him as well
that you know we can't sit on this we we
need to move forward and we need to move
forward quickly and and we will come up
with our response uh and we will give
him that and I raised the concerns that
we had around the storm and break uh and
and some other issues that we've got and
I raised him and he accepted them and he
said he will come back to me with that
so the mood was was was quite buoyant if
I'm honest
um I think he feels like he's he's done
his job in regards to this um and look
if if I look at this at face value key
and when I say face value if I just look
at what he said uh in a statement to uh
Parliament if I looked at that and
nothing else I would say this is
fantastic but the devil is always in the
detail and we have to stop and look at
this and study not just the command
paper but the legal text and the
political the political decoration as
well I think people understand that we
need to do that
okay um so when you raise the concerns
about this break uh storm up break uh he
said he'd come back to you did he give
you a time scale
no he said he'd come back soon
um you know one thing he did say and I
asked him you know what what time frame
are we looking at here for ratification
or a vote in Parliament or anything like
that and he says look he's not going to
give me time frame on that I think he's
giving people time and space to be able
to look at this and I think it's fair
that people do need time and space the
point I've made that I've made
repeatedly is you can't drag this out
for weeks on end you can't drag this out
for months you know you need to come up
with a position on this one way or the
other and that needs to be an informed
position and that just takes a bit of an
analysis as to what we're going to
achieve here you know nobody gets
everything that they want from these
type of negotiations and I think it's
right that any business in Northern
Ireland or any business in Great Britain
who are using Northern Ireland to move
Goods into the European single Market
um need to adhere to EU rules and
regulations and laws but that should not
affect those people in Northern Ireland
who do not
um so so that's an important distinction
that has to be made